prices continue to rise in Las Vegas and
around the country housing has also seen
a significant spike in the last few
years so this comes as eight is dealing
with a crippling shortage of affordable
affordable rental homes Sasha Loftus
spoke with a local family tonight who
shared their first-hand struggle to try
and stay afloat and she joins us now
live in the studio with their story yes
Denise and Brian this family tells me
they feel like they're out of options
since they moved here from Louisiana
less than a year ago they've been close
to living on the street
a local family scrambling to keep a roof
over their heads it breaks my heart they
didn't want to share their identity but
believe it's important to tell their
story the couple says while they both
work full-time it's impossible to make
enough money for a traditional lease so
weekly rentals are their only options
it's always everywhere there's too many
people and they ain't ever two bedrooms
available but with five kids and two
dogs there's rarely enough room and they
say a lot of local shelters are too full
to accommodate them but at the same time
we knew in the back of our head that it
was going to be one day that it wasn't
you know we had too many people
unfortunately situations like this are
far from unique according to eviction
Lab Las Vegas has seen a 56 percent
spike in eviction since 2021. experts
say inflation-driven housing price hikes
are partly to blame Zillow lists a 15
rise in rent prices nationally and
Nevada is dealing with a shortage of
affordable housing for those at or below
the poverty line we tell our kids okay
well we're going to be here for a while
you know and then when we get the note
on our door for people like this feeling
it firsthand it's truly devastating I
need to be cheaper and they need to have
something set up better for families
now the family says they have one more
week left at that weekly rental they're
not sure whether where they're going to
go after that they say they're paying
about 350 a week for one bedroom Brian
and Sasha also spoke with a local animal
rescue that said because of housing
insecurity many people being forced to
surrender their animals which can
trickle down and cause issues at
shelters that are already full